At the end of the last animation I asked
you to share your own stories of uneven
understanding share.
You did more than I could have imagined.
We built one of the Web's largest
collection of asymmetric intelligibility
stories right there in the comments.
You also called me out.
Could I maybe share something personal
about my journey into language?
That's something patrons have asked for
two, since we have a bit of downtime.
Today's a good day to do that.
In my life,
there hasn't just been one thing
that connected me to language.
It's been a bunch of small moments,
little experiences.
Some of these end up in my videos,
so I guess keep watching
to get the full story,
but if I'm sharing personal experiences,
it might have to be this one.
It's not what I expected today,
but there are events,
struggles,
things in my earlier life.
I wouldn't be here without.
These are my scars.
Literally scars at the time.
It's so superficial,
but as a kid I was kind of shy.
It's something I slowly grew out of,
thanks to a happy family team,
sports,
great friends until I ran into
that life wall called adolescence.
And that means different
things to different teens.
I got some of the normal
awkwardness and acne,
but on top of that I began to get serious
scabs and rashes and worse all over my
face,
my hands and my neck.
I tried to cover it up
or at least play it off.
I couldn't always find ways to cope.
Uh,
I'd make it through a school day and I
had rushed to be alone, study or draw,
ride my bike off on my own on tough days.
I remember sitting behind bus benches
instead of waiting up front like a normal
person, just so my latest scars
weren't out there for everyone to see.
Why am I telling you this?
Because it mattered.
I was uncomfortable and struggling to
find worth in my own skin and that made it
tough to connect superficially.
I had to look past my skin in lean on
ways I knew to connect on a deeper level.
I did this with language.
It helped me relate to people,
people with their own scars,
people who pass it and present,
opened up and shared stories of
languages and cultures with me.
They gave me riches more meaningful
than if I'd never had this struggle.
Eventually it took years,
but eventually I got a diagnosis.
My skin was sensitive to fragrances,
laundry,
deodorant, Cologne, shampoo,
hair products, washing dishes.
They were all leaving scars.
I made changes and the scars healed.
That's what they do.
I,
the day my mom helped me take off my
sheets and wash everything and fragrance
free detergent.
I got to leave it behind usually for my
skin and definitely from my mind what
the clucks tick and scars fade.
I get to make up for lost time
for the most part I've moved on,
which is one reason why these
videos take awhile. Yes,
animation is a thing that takes time.
I've learned how true that is,
but there's more to my story in an effort
to be a productive part of our future
world and pay for those
hand baskets of food.
I've been on my own years long
journey to be a better programmer.
Maybe a bit later in life than I expected.
But while you've been watching,
I've been putting in the
work, taking classes, getting
certified coding projects.
This balancing act doesn't pay well, but
in many other ways it's been rewarding.
It even shapes the videos you watch now.
The part of my journey that would become
native Lang is another story when I
shared with patrons,
but I'm compelled to keep coming back
partly because of those earlier days when
language distracted me from my scars.
Well,
I've talked about where I've been. What
about you? What is language meant to you?
Was there a little moment
or a meaningful experience?
I offer patrons much gratitude
for all your support,
and thank you for sticking around
in subscribing for language.